des débris des escaliers des murs en
ruines les dégâts causés par l'incendié
de la station d'épuration d'achères le 3
juillet dernier
plus précisément sur l' usine c'est
naval de saint germain en laye du siaap
chargée de traiter les eaux usées
six mois plus tard les premiers éléments
émergent suite aux expertises sur les
causes de ce sinistre sur deux plus
qu'atteint maintenant sont que plus
particulière et visez donc quatre causes
possibles différentes tous d'origine
électrique
donc on va patienter le temps que
l'espère dur de l'assurance puisse aller
au bout de sa mission
actuellement une installation provisoire
fonctionne pour traiter les eaux usées
pour comprendre et tirer les
conséquences trois audits sont en cours
emmanuelle wargon secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire est venu
constater les dégâts et échanger avec
les parties prenantes
on a lancé de façon très sérieuse toutes
les procédures permettant d'aller au
bout des causes est au bout de
l'amélioration des mesures de précaution
et de prévention
après il manquait un plan de prévention
et d'information des habitants qui sera
validée d'ici quelques jours
probablement d'ici la fin de l'année
et du coup ça permettra d'engager une
discussion plus structurée avec les
riverains sur quoi faire il faut
prévenir et mettent tout en oeuvre pour
que les mesures préventives de sécurité
empêche totalement je dirais une
catastrophe
c'est là-dessus véritablement qui vont
mettre le paquet pour éviter que l'on
passe au niveau pp
c'est à dire c'est trop tard une
nouvelle réunion de suivi doit avoir
lieu fin janvier début février avec les
premiers résultats des audits avec
peut-être les raisons de cet incendie
sur ce site industriel